Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here
and it's time to talk about the big reveals
in Solo: A Star Wars Story and what the film's
ending means for Star Wars, an Obi-Wan Kenobi
movie and possible Solo sequels.
To celebrate the release of a new Star Wars
film, I'm running a Star Wars giveaway for
all my subscribers.
For a chance to win, make sure you're subscribed
to my channel and leave a comment below with
your thoughts about the movie.
Spoilers ahead for the Solo movie, so take
care if you haven't seen it yet.
Let's start with the surprise reveal of Darth
Maul at the end of movie.
If you last saw him get sliced in half by
Obi-Wan Kenobi in The Phantom Menace, you
might be wondering how Maul is still alive.
Well, the Sith Lord miraculously survived
Obi-Wan's blow and drop into the reactor shaft
using the Force to pull himself into an air
vent where he fell into a vat.
Maul ended up being transported to another
planet where he was eventually rescued by
his brother.
Fans of The Clone Wars and Rebels animated
TV series will have seen him in on the show
where he acquired robotic legs which you can
also see in the hologram of him in the Solo
movie.
Maul is a popular prequel villain that some
fans have been hoping would return in a live-action
movie, and this brief appearance at the end
of Solo could be setting up the Sith Lord
as a series big bad who could span across
multiple Solo and other anthology and prequel
movies.
And speaking to Maul was Qi'ra, who he commands
to come to him on Dathomir where they will
work together more closely, which means we'll
likely see Emilia Clarke returning in any
new movie with Darth Maul.
By the way, notice in this scene that Darth
Maul wears the same kind of pendant we saw
Qi'ra wear when she saw Han in the Cantina
scene, it's a Crimson Dawn half-logo necklace.
We get to see a darker side of Qi'ra in her
scene with Darth Maul where she seems to have
no trouble in lying to him claiming it was
Beckett who killed Dryden Vos when of course
she did.
And there are numerous hints earlier in the
movie too about unspeakable things that Qi'ra's
done.
As Beckett told Han at the end of the film,
'she's a survivor.'
Qi'ra's part in Solo ends with her piloting
Dryden's Space Yacht off to meet with Maul,
but as she leaves you can see she is a little
conflicted looking out at Han on the cliff
top below.
The filmmakers have said "Qi'ra is probably
the most complex character in the film" and
there are still things we need to learn about
her.
For example, we don't know what Qi'ra had
to do to get off Corellia or what happened
during the three years that she and Han were
separated or how she rose up the ranks of
the Crimson Dawn so quickly.
It's possible that's she's compromised in
some way to Darth Maul and maybe she thinks
she could put Han's life in danger if she
goes with him.
Qi'ra does also seem resigned to her fate
saying to Han earlier in the movie that it's
not about winning but how long you can stay
in the game.
And because she's a prequel character who
never appears or is mentioned in the original
trilogy, it's safe to say that Qi'ra probably
won't live beyond future sequels.
By the way, there's a very cool musical easter
egg in the Maul and Qi'ra scene with some
of John Williams' "Duel of the Fates" playing
in the background.
"Duel of the Fates" is a musical theme that
Williams composed for the prequel trilogy
and first played in The Phantom Menace during
the lightsaber battle between Darth Maul,
Qui-Gon and Obi-Wan.
So, what could we see happen with Darth Maul
in a future movie?
Well, previously in The Clone Wars, Maul set
up a criminal organisation called the Shadow
Collective.
In its heyday, the Collective totalled five
major criminal groups under its alliance,
one of which was the Hutt Clan which had been
forced to join.
The Hutts later abandoned the group and there
was a very big hint at the end of Solo that
the "big-shot gangster" they're heading off
to meet on Tatooine is Jabba the Hutt, meaning
that a sequel could have Han and Chewie forced
to go up against Maul, perhaps on behalf of
Jabba.
Another member of Maul's Shadow Collective
was the Pyke Syndicate, and one of that gang's
members also made a brief appearance in Solo
during the Kessel scenes.
I also thought the placement of Mandalorian
armour in Dryden Vos's study is a nod to the
upcoming Boba Fett anthology movie that Logan
director James Mangold is working on for Lucasfilm.
Now, I do also think that there's an alternative
or additional movie that Darth Maul and perhaps
Qi'ra could appear in – which is the heavily
rumoured Obi-Wan Kenobi movie that a lot of
fans have been hoping for.
Interestingly, Ewan McGregor appeared at the
Solo premiere even giving interviews.
Obi-Wan struck the seemingly lethal blow to
Darth Maul in Episode 1, so the two have history,
but the potential wrinkle is that much of
this has been explored in the canon TV shows,
with the two even facing off for one fateful
final duel on Tatooine.
However, not everyone's familiar with the
animated series, so we could see a live-action
recreation of that duel in an Obi-Wan movie.
The movie might also change some elements
of that story which has already been told
in the TV shows, although that might irk some
fans.
But both Darth Maul and Obi-Wan are hugely
popular characters in the fandom and if Lucasfilm
sense there's an opportunity to capitalise
on that, I suspect they'll take it.
A possible though maybe less likely option
is that Darth Maul's reappearance here is
to set up a major role for him in Jon Favreau's
new live-action TV series.
I'm really pleased to see that Ray Park returned
as Darth Maul.
Park played him in The Phantom Menace, and
in Solo, Maul's voice is provided by Sam Witwer
who's voiced the villain in the animated shows.
Park seems like a really nice guy and when
I interviewed him before the new trilogy kicked
off, this is what he said about coming back
to Star Wars.
"But deep down, I'd really like to come back
as Darth Maul."
"That's what I wanna do."
"I would do..
I would go crazy, go mental, lock myself in
a cabin, go.. you know."
"Do the whole method and.. for two or three
months.
You know."
"Spear fishing and stuff and just to play
the character again."
As well as links to the prequels, Solo, of
course, connects to the original trilogy and
the reveal of Enfys Nest and her Cloud Rider
gang seems to be a nod to the early days of
the Rebel Alliance.
And when Enfys Nest says to Han: "You could
come with us; we could use someone like you",
it's an interesting parallel with how Han
asked Luke to go with him and abandon the
Rebel Alliance, just before the attack on
the Death Star.
"Why don't you come with us?"
"You're pretty good in a fight.
We could use you."
"Come on.
Why don't you take a look around?"
"You know what's about to happen, what they're
up against."
Now, Han doesn't go with Enfys Nest, preferring
instead to work on a big score for someone
like Jabba the Hutt, but like Qi'ra said to
Han "you're the good guy", and the Solo movie
is planting the seed for Han to eventually
do the right thing.
Because Han did come back at the last minute
during the Death Star battle to save Luke.
Later in Solo, Han tracks down Lando for a
final bet to win the Millennium Falcon.
When he meets Lando, they hug just like they
do when they see each other in The Empire
Strikes Back.
But Han, who knew that Lando was cheating
when he played him earlier in the Solo movie,
uses the hug to steal the card that Lando
had hidden up his sleeve.
Which is how Han eventually won the Millennium
Falcon and given that both Han and Lando cheated
in their Sabacc games, it brings an extra
level of meaning to this line from Empire:
"What have you done to my ship?"
"Your ship?"
"Hey, remember, you lost her to me fair and
square."
The other important moment at the end of Solo
is Han's final confrontation with Beckett.
Over the course of the movie, we can detect
Beckett's cynical influence on Han.
Beckett betrayed him to Dryden Vos, telling
Han earlier in the movie "assume everyone
will betray you and you'll never be disappointed",
and then, of course, Qi'ra did leave Han at
the end too.
In his stand-off against Beckett, Han doesn't
hesitate to shoot first, demonstrating he's
internalised these sceptical views about honour
and betrayal and, of course, reminding us
of that scene with Greedo in A New Hope.
So, what did you think of Solo and how does
it compare with your other favourite Star
Wars movies?
And do you have any predictions on how Darth
Maul, Qi'ra or Han and Chewie could return
in a sequel?
Make sure you're subscribed and leave me a
comment about the movie for a chance to win
a Star Wars Funko Pop.
I'm working on some more Solo videos, so be
sure to ring the notification bell to keep
up-to-date with all my new uploads.
And if you enjoyed this, likes and shares
are always very much appreciated, plus you
can check out more of my ending explained
and theories videos by tapping here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers.